REMOTE CART
DAS-Library of Congress-Story
Time for Young Readers-(Youtube)
10:30 a.m. to 11:30 a.m. (EST)
April 27, 2018
CAPTIONING PROVIDED BY:
ALTERNATIVE COMMUNICATION
SERVICES, LLC
www.CaptionFamily.com.
*  *  *  *  *
This is being provided in a
rough draft format.
Communication
Access Realtime Translation
(CART) is provided in order to
facilitate communication access
and may not be a totally
verbatim record of the
proceedings.
* * * *
»:  Welcome to story time at the
library of congress.  It is fun
to see them faces and new faces
as well.  I am Leanne Potter and
I direct the outreach at the
library and many of you know
about a month and a half ago the
library entered in to an
exciting partnership with Dolly
part and imagination Library.
The imagination Library gusty
wind Dolly part and came to the
library, we were celebrating the
fact that her organization had
distributed its 100
million book to children around
this country and elsewhere.  We
were so excited about it and the
library entered into a library
with the
imagination Library through a
series of six livestream story
times.  This is one of our
livestream story times and why I
am yelling at you is to remind
you that this is being filmed.
It is live on the Internet and
we should all be very aware of
that.  If you don't want to be
famous, now is your chance bail.
And I am going to ask really
nicely something important.  And
our last storytime, we had a
little signing going on and some
of you remember it was like it
became a jungle gym and we
really cannot let that happen.
It makes our camera crew nervous
and it makes me nervous and it
makes us all a little nervous so
if you could make sure the kids
hang out on the floor, that
would be great and please fully
participate in storytime and
enjoy.
This morning are very special
author
and guest is Laura Murray and
she is
going to be reading to us about
the gingerbread man and the fire
truck and we will get to that in
just a minute, but the very
first thing we are going to do
is watch a quick video
introduction
from the library of Congress,
thank you.
»:  I want to welcome you to
this very special storytime at
the library.  I love this.  ,
don't you??  It is so much time
to let our imaginations run
wild.
We are starting to be teamed up
with, Ms. Dolly Parton
Imagination Library to introduce
you to some wonderful authors
who will share their stories
with us.
Dolly Parton's work through her
Imagination Library is
awe-inspiring and
she and our team have given away
over 100 million books to help
encourage
young readers across the world.
Here at the Library of Congress
we share that passion for
developing young leaders and we
know that the best way to
encourage people like you to
read is to make reading fun!  So
that is what we do.
I hope you enjoy today's story
time more.   And I hope you keep
reading at home and having fun.
Today we will warm up by singing
songs, touching your toes, and
then get comfortable and get
ready to hear a story!  Now
let's get started!
» LAURA MURRAY:  Welcome
everybody to storytime and the
library of Congress.
We are here in this beautiful
room and we have a very great
story.  I am sorry.  I am not
on.  There I am.  Welcome to
everyone and everyone out there
on the Internet to storytime at
the Library of Congress and here
we are
in the beautiful Pavilion and my
name is
Caroline and this is Laura
Murray, the author of the
gingerbread man.  So today we
are going to start off with our
hello, song and we just need to
learn a little bit of sign.
So in salute for hello, and then
friends is at the index finger
one way
and then the other way, condom
hugging,
friends, hello, friends three
times.
Hello, friends and then it is
time -- touch or watch -- to say
hello!  Okay?  All right.  .
Let’s go.
Hello, friends, hello,  friends,
hello, friends; it's time to say
hello!
(Applause)
Good job.  All right.
Let's do our brains.
Open, shut them, open, shut
them, put
them in your lap, lap, lap.
Close them,
put them near your chin, Chin,
open up
your little mouths -- let them
in --
open, shut them, open them, shut
them,
give a little clap, clap, clap.
Open them, shut them, open, shut
them.
Put them in your lap, lap, lap.
Creep them, call them, creep
them, called them, right up to
your  chin, chin, chin.
Open up your little mouths and
do not let them in.  Yeah!
Yeah!
(Applause)
All right.  So Laura, can you
read us some of the gingerbread
man, loose on the fire truck?
» LAURA MURRAY:  Thank you, so
much.  I am a very excited
person to be here today.  My
name is Laura Murray and I am a
children's author and I also
write the words to the stories.
And my stories are about a
gingerbread man!  And there is a
series of them.  The one at that
we are going to read
today is the second in the
series.  It is called, "The
gingerbread man,
loose on the fire truck" but
before we read this, you might
want to know why there is a
gingerbread man on the fire
truck?   And it starts with the
very first book.
So a gingerbread man is made by
a
classroom full of kids and he
gets to be part of their class!
And since he is part of their
class, then he gets to go on
field trips with them.
So his first field trip is to
the fire station!  So let's get
started!  Now I would like you
to help me if you can.  Would
you like to know how?  Okay.
We will read a story in this is
our plan.
When I say gingerbread, you say
man!  So let's try it --
gingerbread.
»:  Man.
» LAURA MURRAY:  Gingerbread.
» LAURA MURRAY:  You guys got
it.  Let's try it with the
title.  The gingerbread.
»:  Man.
» LAURA MURRAY:  Loose on the
fire chief -- fire truck by
Laura Murray, that is
me because I wrote the words,
illustrated by Michael Lowery.
He drew the what do you think?
The pictures!  The pictures.
Okay.  So here we go.
On a bright Monday morning, my
teacher breezed in. Let's all
make a circle. It's time to
begin. She winked and then
whispered, our field trip's
today.
The classroom erupted with
shouts of, "Hooray!
"
Very good
We're riding the bus to the big
fire station, to meet
firefighters and Spot, their
Dalmatian.
So Sophia leaned down and said,
"You're coming too.  You're our
gingerbread man -- we wouldn't
leave you.
Just jump in my backpack, I'll
give you a ride. There's a
pocket for you over here on the
side.
The pocket was cozy. I peeked
from the top. The bus drove 4
miles then came to a
stop In front of the building
with shiny red
doors stood two firefighters
from Company 4.
One had on gear for a quick
demonstration  and standing
beside him was Spot, the
Dalmatian.
That's right.
And the firefighter has on
goggles, a
helmet, and oxygen tank, a
flashlight, an axe, gloves, and
boots.  And in Spot the dog!
I was jostled and jiggled as
kids moved about. Then I fell
from the pocket right on the
dog's snout!
Is that a good place for a
gingerbread man to be?  Ohno!
Spot sniffed at my face, taking
one sticky lick. I needed a
trick to get out of there quick!
He tossed me up high with his
mouth
open wide, but I flipped toward
his tail and slid down like a
slide.
Weeee!
My feet hit the ground. I took
off for the station. But right
on my heels was that hungry
Dalmatian. I'll run and I'll
dodge, as fast as I can. I'm not
a dog bone! I'm the gingerbread
man!
Very good
The class didn't notice. They
tried on black boots and
helmets, and air tanks, and big
heavy suits.
Do you see the gingerbread man
there writing?  And who is
behind him?
Spot the Dalmatian!  Oh, my
goodness!
I dashed to the fire truck,
jumped in a seat. Whew! I was
almost a sweet doggy treat!.
Wow!  He got away
I hopped on the steering will,
gave it a spin -- and yelled
out, "Honk Honk!"  with a big
cookie grin. The wheel spun past
gauges and switches and knobs --
all kinds of buttons that do
different jobs.
I'll vroom and I'll zoom, as
fast as I can. I'll steer this
big truck, I'm the gingerbread
man!
That is where I am going to
pause for just a minute.  We are
going to break the book up into
two sections and we will do two
songs and then finish the book!
All right!  Okay!  All right!
So we need to make a gingerbread
man!
So we are going to go bake,
bake, bake
a gingerbread -- add sugar and
spice, and everything nice.
Look!  We made our friend.
Okay.  One more time.  It is
going to be row your boat.
La, la, la, la, la, la, la, la,
bake,
bake, bake all day, bake a
gingerbread, add spice and
everything nice, look!  We made
a friend.  One more time.
Bake, bake, bake all day, make a
gingerbread.  Add sugar and
spice and everything nice, look!
We made a friend!  Yeah!  Good
job!
(Applause)
All right.
Now a classic about a little boy
having an adventure.  We are
going to make a candle with one
finger and then the other is
going to be Jack and he is going
to go up to the candle and he is
going to jump over it.  Okay?
Jack be nimble, Jack be quick,
Jack jump over the candlestick!
All right.  Go the other way.
Jack be nimble, Jack be quick,
Jack jump over the candlestick!
Good job!
(Applause)
Now the other half of our story.
Okay.
Now let's see what happens with
the gingerbread man.  Does he
get away from Spot?  How does he
help?  Okay?
Then I heard someone whistle.
Spot trotted away. So I jumped
through the window without a
delay.
I landed on a top of a big
several silver bowl. Oh, no! I
cried out as I leapt for a pole.
I shimmied right up and I sprang
from the top and then jumped on
a bed with a big belly flop.
Who does belly flops on their
bed?  Anybody?
(Laughter)
There were several more bunks
with their covers pulled tight
for each firefighter who stayed
through the night.
I bounced on each bed on my way
to the
door, then into a room with a
bright checkered floor.
Where is he going?
I peeked around the corner and
smelled something yummy -- a
grumbling sound rumbled up from
my tummy.
I spotted a fireman filling up
bowls with five-alarm chili and
buttery rolls.
There he is, down Then all of a
sudden I heard a loud noise.
there
Woooo! Fire! One shouted, "No
lunch for us, boys." They rushed
to the bunk room and slid down
the pole.
I followed behind them then
peered down the hole.
Spot wasn't there -- a sure sign
of good luck.
So I slipped down the pole and
then jumped on the truck. I'll
ride to the rescue, as fast as I
can. I want to help, too! I'm
the gingerbread man! Weeeee!
Can you do that?   Weeeee!
went the sirens the lights
flashed around. As I zoomed past
my classmates below on the
ground.
We sped through the streets and
I clung to the back. near
ladders and hoses piled up in a
stack.
There he is
The engine pulled up,
firefighters jumped out. They
rushed to the hydrant and opened
the spout.
I spied a large house with a
shed near the back.
Smoke rose from its window, all
sooty and black.
I'll put out that fire, as fast
as I can. I know I can help! I'm
the gingerbread man!
I grabbed the hose nozzle and
gave it a pull.
But that hose whipped and bumped
like a rodeo bull!.
Because he is so small, is NT?
The water wooshed out and it
doused the old shed. And the
powerful spray shot the hat off
my head.
He lost his hat! The chief ran
up quickly and dove on the hose.
She crawled her way up until we
came nose to nose.
"Looked everyone! It's a
gingerbread man!
Now where did you come from,"
Said the Fire Chief Anne.
"I came with the children to
visit the station.
But I almost got eaten by Spot,
the Dalmatian.
I had to escape from that hungry
crumb-snatcher, so I jumped on
the truck when I heard your
dispatcher.
" "Good thinking, smart cookie!
We're glad you hopped on. You
wrestled that hose till the fire
was gone.
"
Did he help put out the fire?
Yes, he did
We packed up the truck and
drove back to the station.
Can you drive back to the
station?
We pulled in the drive to a
standing ovation.
Can you clap?
(Applause)
That is what innovation means.
Your gingerbread guy was a
brave little man! "He doused
every flame," announced Fire
Chief Anne The children
applauded and shouted, "Yeah!
" They held me up high, yelling,
"You saved the day!
"
And in the firefighter said you
are really a hero.
You're part of our crew. But
you're missing your hat so we
have one for you A shiny red
helmet from Company 4! There are
more for your classmates
stacked up by the door I tried
on my helmet and shouted
"Woohoo!
I'm a gingerbread man and a
fireman too!
"
And that is the end.
(Applause)
You guys did a great job finding
all of the man's and helping me
read that book.  Wow!  Nice job!
Very good!
Now we are going to do a little
finger play and will you show us
how to do it?  Yes.  This one is
about five gingerbread men.  Can
everyone hold up their five
gingerbread men and we are going
to count down.  Now this has
hand movements to it.
This says
five gingerbread man in a row.
Not going to eat them, no,
no,no, but
they looked so sweet from head
to toe
, crunch, Monch,
oh, oh!
If we ate one, how many do we
have left?
4 4 gingerbread men in a row,
not going to eat them, no, no,
no.
But they look so sweet, from
head to
toe, crunch, munch, oh, oh!.  If
we have format, we take away
one, how many do we have left?
3.  Three gingerbread man in a
row, not
going to eat them, no, no, no.
But they look so sweet from head
to toe, crunch, munch, oh, oh!.
Now we had three and we take
away one.  How many do we have
left?  Two.
Two gingerbread men in a row,
not
going to eat them, no, no, no!
But they look so sweet from head
to toe.  Crunch, munch, oh, oh!
.  Now we had two and we take
away one.  We have how many
left?  One.
One gingerbread man in a row,
not
going to eat them, no, no, no!
But they look so good and suite
from
head to toe, crunch, munch, oh,
oh!.
Now we had one and we take it
away, how many do we have left?
Zero?
Now this one is just a little
bit different.
No gingerbread man in a row, was
going to eat them, no, no, no!
But they look so sweet from head
to toe,
crunch, munch, oh, well!  All
gone.  Very good!
(Applause)
You guys did a great job.
»:  There they go.
All right.  We had a dog in that
story, didn't we?  Who remembers
the name of that dog?
Dalmatian?  All right.  Good.
So we are going to sing an old
classic
about where is my dog
la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la,
la, la,
oh,, oh, where, has my little
dog gone, aware where can he be?
With his tail cut short and his
ears
cut long, oh, where, oh, where
can he be?
Now let's make it a girl dog.
Oh, where, oh, where has my
little dog gone?  Oh,, oh, where
can she be?
With her ears cut short and her
tail
cut long, oh, where aware can
she be?  Very good.
(Applause)
All right.  It is time for our
goodbye song.
And goodbye is just a little way
and the rest, you all know.
Goodbye friend, goodbye friend,
goodbye friend; it's time to say
goodbye.
»:  Thank you for coming to
story time with Laura Murray.
Give her a big hand.
(Applause)
All right.  Okay.  Very good!